families and rescue workers in eastern
India are identifying bodies after the
country's worst trained disaster in
decades at least 275 people have been
killed and prime minister Narendra Modi
has promised to punish those responsible
preliminary reports suggests a signal
error may be to blame Sarah Hyatt
reports
four diggers is what it takes to move a
single train carriage
from above the scale of the destruction
becomes clear
ground Around the Clock clean up
operation of India's worst train crash
in more than 20 years
20 30 peoples were dumped at a place
and Scattered people are screaming so
scene was so so difficult that you can't
understand to whom you are going to
serve us to whom you are going to rescue
first
families have been trying to identify
their missing relatives
they're saying you'll get to find out at
the hospital I've been to all the
hospitals and they have found out
nothing I'm going to bhupanishwa to find
out I just need my husband I don't want
anything else
such was the scale of damage that some
could only identify their loved ones
from personal belongings such as jewelry
others will be identified through DNA
testing
Railway Minister Ashwini y Schnell says
a signaling error caused the pile up
yes we share my point it's about the
point machine and electronic
interlocking in this matter the change
in the electronic interlocking caused
this accident and whoever did it and
whatever are the reasons will be known
after the investigation
on Saturday prime minister Narendra Modi
visited the survivors in hospitals he
promised them that those responsible
will face Justice
more than 12 million people use 14 000
trains across India every day most of
the train accidents are caused by human
error or outdated signaling equipment
leaving many people in India questioning
the safety of one of the largest railway
systems in the world
Al Jazeera
um Sharif is at the site of the crash in
balasore
after a rescue operation that's lasted
more than 24 hours the focus now is on a
cleanup operation that is underway right
here at the site of the massive accident
that took place on Friday two passenger
trains and one good train the Calamity
is for everyone to see out here they're
carriages that have been thrown on
either side of the Railway track and
there are people out here who are trying
to put the Rail lines back together
their teams here dozens of them from the
State national disaster management
there's the police force there's the
Army the police has gotten up much of
this area and plenty of rail workers who
are out here moving trucks trying to put
them in line moving Stones putting wood
blocks and there is a rail coach that
just went by that was inspecting the
overhead wires that have all snapped
how did we come to this that's what the
railway officials are trying to find out
the railway Minister has said there was
some kind of interlocking failure and
prime minister has said those who are
guilty will face the consequences well
for millions of Indians who take these
trains across the length and breadth of
the country thousands of trains each day
want to know what happened they also
want to say that it's fixed so that
their loved ones will be safe on the
trains but a more immediate
um
Focus right now is not far from here our
families who've managed to made it are
actually looking for loved one at
hospitals and at the morgue and they
really want to have answers
for Al Jazeera